[Dave] So for question 4, we want to see that you understand
how to use and make assignments to variables.
The question is "Write Python code that stores the distance in meters
that light travels in one nanosecond in the variable nanodistance."
The variables below are predefined for you.
We're storing the speed of light in the variable speed_of_light.
And that's 299,800,000.
And I have the dot at the end of this to make sure that
when you do arithmetic we'll get decimal variables instead
of just doing integer arithmetic on the speed of light.
The second variable is nano_per_second,
and there are 1 billion nanoseconds in 1 second.
And your goal is to write code that assigns to the variable
nanodistance the distance in meters that light travels in 1 nanosecond.
And if you've done that correctly, after you run your code,
when you print the value of nanodistance,
it should output 0.2998,
indicating that light travels almost 30 centimeters in 1 nanosecond.